so what part of Memphis are you from I'm
from the East the East who else is from
the east from these two times okay so
yeah hey guys by the way one of my
favorite interviews I've done in a long
time hey way to go way to go over there
uh
super nice guy well I mean he's he was
nice to me yeah yeah super nice to me is
he on your guys's label no he's not okay
shots of finesse great guy uh he dope is
here he's I love I love the way he raps
and he'd be he's like kind of like the
new age sugar-free or too short because
he'd just be rapping about pimping and
[__] and that [__] reminds me it just
reminds me of my childhood because all
my like when I was a kid I loved you
know too short is yeah
so too short
his whole [__] was he's a pimp yeah same
thing with sugar-free you don't know who
that is though no yeah all my time you
got to get hip on that sugar free okay
you know what I mean so he's from the
East side anybody else not that I know
okay so finesse two times shout out to
him yeah who would you consider to be
like if we were to put together the
Mountain West almost at Mount Westmore
you see um brainwashed by Ice Cube 42
short and Snoop Dogg the Mount Rushmore
of Memphis hip-hop who's on the who's on
the was it four people four see look I'm
[__] up
well I'm a guy hits that Gangster Boo
cause that's my girl rest in peace
Legend you know what I'm saying and
I would say
hell
Dolph guys
damn two people who aren't with us
anymore that's something to think of
this looks
who is who is
uh
project back [__] yeah I was hoping
you're gonna okay I'm loving this so far
you're [__] on point yeah okay
and oh
trying to think who else from Memphis I
could say
[Music]
oh no Juicy J I don't know Juicy J
that's a great four I like that yeah
would you say Obviously Gangsta Boo is
uh she was one of the nicer ladies that
I've met I had a couple of dope
encounters with her
uh big loss in hip-hop she obviously I
think probably doesn't get enough
respect in terms of like when we talk
about like all-time great female rappers
like what was your relationship like
with her man she was really supportive
of everything that we did like always
commenting like shaking in with us and
stuff and like she's always encouraging
us and remind us how dope we are and
stuff so really like when we start
popping out this one Falls really start
going back and paying attention so like
I agree she really didn't in my opinion
fully get her flowers while she was here
she was just still feel like she was
just still warming up you know what I'm
saying I think she was gonna come hard
this year